nos pregunta cuál es el valor del punto
azul en la recta numérica este punto
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
antes de que lo hagamos juntos hagámoslo
juntos observen que este punto se
encuentra entre vamos a ver esta es la
posición de las décimas y esta es la
posición de las centésimas
aquí tenemos tres centésimas y de este
lado hay cuatro centésimas así que
nuestro punto está entre tres y cuatro
centésimas y el espacio que hay entre
tres centésimas y cuatro centésimas
está dividido en diez partes iguales
entonces si todo esto es un centésimo si
la diferencia entre esto y esto es de
0.01 centésimas entonces cada décima
parte de eso será una milésima esto
corresponde a una décima parte de una
sentencia es decir una milésima así que
es igual a 0.001 tenemos el número uno
en la posición de las milésimas y una
forma de verlo es que si este número es
0.03 ya estamos en tres centésimas pero
ahora veamos cuántas milésimas
necesitamos agregar para llegar a este
valor vamos a ver necesitamos una
milésima dos milésimas tres milésimas
cuatro milésimas cinco milésimas seis
milésimas siete milésimas y ocho
milésimas entonces empezamos en tres
centésimas y después agregamos ocho
milésimas agregamos 0.008 para llegar a
este valor así que al sumar esos dos
valores tenemos tres centésimas y en la
siguiente posición están las milésimas
que es donde escribimos ocho así que
este punto se encuentra en 0 punto 0 38
o dicho de otra manera 38 milésimas
porque tres centésimas son 30 milésimas
pero de cualquier manera este es el
valor del punto gráfico
en la recta numérica 0.0 38